it doesn't matter how you get this arm
what are you trying to do to stop him
from posting okay
it doesn't matter if you want to come
this way
fine
boom
so a lot of your guard attacks are
requiring him to be in this 45 degree
angle
of his torso they work much better there
then he's all the way up there
or he's all the way putting pressure
down here okay
so when you start
administratively you got to take him
into that 45 okay
so the way that i was taking him into
that 45 was with the knee pull you see
now he's in that 45 i can't make him
come all the way down because now i
won't be able to get the scissor in
place okay so we're starting
administratively
move him to that 45
then you do the shrimp okay
make sure you're bringing him on you
before you do the scissor sweep
and you connect so that his falling
momentum pulls you up it's not an
abdominal exercise
other than you're using your center to
stay connected to that falling
inertia okay
okay so again this is an administrative
starting position
uh this isn't where you usually find
this stuff especially if you're doing
jiu jitsu he will move his body into
that 45 position on his own that's the
opening okay this agency with the knee
pull
um
the guy has to be much less skilled than
you
okay um
sometimes when the guy feels the scissor
sweep come in he'll open his legs okay
again some beginners will go like this
because they're not very flexible and
they're trying to relieve their ankles
and knees but there's no way he can stop
the uh the uh knee pull now because his
legs don't offer any resistance okay so
he has to rely totally on his arms but
it's easy to get rid of the arms and
then he can't do anything again so
only beginners start out so wide
most people are trying to
correct this upward posture
or make more integrity in it because
they know the 45 is jacking him up okay
so he could take that away he could use
his legs and his core
and i cannot do the knee pull okay he
opens his legs like this he only gets
his core and his legs and i'm gonna get
the knee pull every time okay so usually
they will feel
uh
the scissor in place
and that's when he'll open okay he's
trying to base out there all right so
you'll feel the resistance
just follow the initial movement come up
this is going to do a curve out and back
okay not just out not just back
out and then back and then the
and the same connection into
[Music]
so if you want to start there it's okay
for drilling but don't bring that into
your spine or your flow training okay so
i do the same exact technique
boom
pop
he'll open up for me
and then
here
sweep
pop
okay
at some point you turned him over and
you had the underhook under the head
okay
um you're going to want to try to keep
his head open so you don't want him to
tuck this way
okay
keep his head open
and maybe if you have the arm you're
going to let go of the arm okay
and what you're going to do i'm going to
open this up so you can see you want
your knuckles flat so don't squeeze your
fists make a flat flat fist
and that'll go right here on the side of
his neck okay
and you'll have a lvnr here
come around take that
hook
hold your own wrist
and press this into him as you bring
your weight forward into that okay you
can always increase pressure by starting
to turn
but you don't want to close that off
okay
so
whichever sweep you're going to do
just drill that
so whichever sweep you want to do
um
there it is
here in place
all right
don't wait so long to tap but if you
don't feel the blood pressure in your
head and eyes ears change
let them know that's not it
okay
too high too low to right to left two
front to back okay
go